and uh what is going on with your head
well i won worse drip right laziest
laziest
whatever it is when i won that i thought
something with coffee right like
because i used an espresso machine i
thought laziest drip coffee
so i was like oh that's that's bad but
it's not too bad then i discovered it
was about clothes
and you know i'm like the king of
fashions and i thought it was i'm
watching so you're wondering so you won
lazy's dripping you somehow came with
even worse drinks yeah
so why that's my game why the heck yeah
best drip whatever it's called next year
and this is the first step to making
that happen
people are people probably clicked on
this video on the thumbnail of like
this chris and they're probably like
what happened to chris
chris for a new a new year but where are
we what is this place oh yeah yeah so
you're the first guest
for the new studio how do you find it
you guys used to record in a brim
cupboard
a well decorated broom cupboard but it
bring cupboard nonetheless
but this is like what can only be
described as a bonds villains
and uh there was like an uber guy he was
equally confused we sort of made a team
effort like he got me through the first
door
security door and then i got him through
this door
sort of a team tag team effort to get in
this ridiculous building
it is massive we could like have a game
of cricket in there
most british thing you never say that it
is cool it's quite cool yeah really at
my depth now
but yeah we got chris back for the third
time he wanted to assert dominance as
soon as he we
he found out that we got a new studio so
chris is like
the first guest we've ever had which
literally the show the second episode on
the new
in the new studio right yeah yeah the
second episode but chris
was not only our first guest ever but he
was the first guest of this year
and now he's the first guest on the news
studio just just knocking out all the
first and i won the
the best guest and the best trip for the
worst laziest yeah congratulations about
that yeah
we do we do have something for you
that's the reason yeah
i come here to get an award a physical
tangible monetary
award monetary
before you open it do you want to give a
speech or something like a little
acceptance yeah
thank you you are my favorite everyone
that voted where strip
i hate you you're wrong
and i'm going to prove you wrong in the
next year but this is this is a guess
this is an award that uh all three of us
were like you know
why not it's an award
it looks like a bomb in there the team
the team doesn't help
open your eyes special bombs that only
kills the person
is actually good yeah i love it
[Music]
hold it to the camera first hold to the
camera first so it's some sort of image
is it the right way is it yeah somehow
we got it the right way first time
everyone is laughing everyone behind the
camera and ready three
two one
you'll forever have that immortalized
now who drew this
i'm coming for you who did this
i'm gonna use the full force of the
abroad in japan media empire to find the
person that drew this and bring them to
justice
what is it this is like a manga
yeah it's a website so this is a webtoon
that one of our fans is making
about trash he's characterized all of us
and i gotta say i mean like
a [ __ ] balloon what is that
i saw i saw this on twitter the trash
tastes fantastic
i'm in a manga and i clicked through and
it was this
and i was like which one am i my oh
[Laughter]
i remember that i remember the message
you gave me too because he sent me a
screenshot of this and
after it just said you [ __ ] what
i mean like it does look like me if we
if we remove the lower half
kids myself shockingly like
i did ask when we got this frame like
can we get a kim jong-un sized
yeah like massive one that you can like
put on the wall and we just
pray to everyone taking out the bullet
train back to center
this character it's not even called like
chris or abroad it's just called
a big mouth big mouth
yeah i think i think in the webtoon we
all have like special powers that
are kind of synonymous to our
personalities
i really hope this character has
redemption on where he
gets then he saves the world he gets the
girl because that's just an atrocity but
it does look cool
artists who made this yeah put that in a
very special place in my apartment
in japan yeah this better be on the set
yeah i'll think about it
thank you it's the thought that counts a
lot of effort into that exactly yeah
i mean it's a fitting prize yeah is it
i thought i'd be like a gold bar or
something yeah why would we give you a
gold billion
this is trash tasting yeah i think i
could sell off when my channel goes down
the toilet
i've got the trash taste prize i can
sell that off that's like worth nothing
it's good i think how dare you thank you
very much we put a lot of
we put a lot of love and effort into
this absolutely for you this can listen
live on the table for this episode for
this episode fantastic
i'd like is is this what is there more
like anger of this coming out
i didn't think i gave up like two or
three months ago
i think the guy is making a new chapter
every week or two weeks ago something
like that redemption
yeah don't give him an idea it takes
time to draw things chris
especially
that's like 70 of the image is just me
it's great you're like the center of
attention right exactly you're right in
the middle
you're pushing away your competition
redemption arc and i'll be very happy
that's that's you know next one just has
to be like this but with
this hat on him
yeah is that something you normally wear
chris or is it something you just wear
i've never seen you wear a hat i've got
a collection of 100 yen hats this was
100 yen
right in japan you
this is actually like a basketball
saying right
you know putting the ball through the
hoop probably maybe
only one of my friends knew that and
he's like a top basketball guy but he's
like it sounds like you want to have sex
with dwayne
johnson it doesn't matter it does a bit
but like counting the rocks
it's just so bizarre you know so i have
a collection of these sort of tacky hats
at my apartment
now i'm actually wearing them and you
really you have a collection of tacky
hats and you're like how dare you give
me lazy
let me wear this tacky hat yeah let me
wear this hat does give off
like very much bad energy yeah pretty
sure my dad has worn the same hat before
i'll take it i like the hat let's get
best ripped